it's a yearly blitz arena i'm joining
two hours late
okay um
i was going to say that i
would berserk the early games but i
don't think i'll bizarre this opponent
i've got a chance of
of getting to your king oh morning then
you've got a chance of getting to my
king
i forgot to turn off the other did
something like
knight f6 i should turn off yasser
i'm gonna start the the first game with
pentatonic just to
try and get him a more calm state
this move
queen d4
[Music]
i'm trying to make sense of uh
of queen d4
there's also this move
but then takes
takes in queen a4
i'm gonna try this
the point is if takes i take with queen
hitting the rook and then takes takes
i'll still be threatening d4
really
it's d4a3
hello to more people
good to see you guys
okay i'll just castle
and bishop here
thank you ntf
something for four months
unwavable
[Music]
take me all the ways
okay i should focus here only in the
first game
if i play queen d6 or is this move queen
c5
i lose a pawn i win a pawn
so uh for those just joining
i recently woke up from a nap
so my voice is still kind of warming up
and
uh hello son
oh hello red dev welcome back
this is the first game of the stream
it's a yearly blitz arena um
it's a six hour long tournament
and
it's five minutes
[Music]
let's take with pawn
rook c1 is probably coming
rook c1 queen v6 probably
11 month gang
hey happy 11 to starbug
resilient welcome back i'm doing well
it's going to take a few games for me to
like fully
awaken and warm up
welcome to barry
wait where is barry from barry from mia
standers
whoa me too eleven month gang
hey happy eleven
do you prefer pentatonic or gin tonic
i i think i prefer penta with my tonic
i'm still a newbie
oh it's okay
every grandmaster was once a newbie
f2 is a bit tender
i have this move
so a5
a5 actually looks nice
if b5 we trade
i was thinking a3 would hang in the end
but maybe not
this takes takes takes and white defends
[Music]
hey i appreciate the raid from sao
oh salad 73
hi eric thanks for your contents
for one year with prime
i do appreciate the people who sub with
prime consistently i know it's sometimes
easy to forget
to renew the sub
if c5 i i lose a pawn
[Music]
um
i really want to do things against
f2 i also have d4 here
and d4 looks enticing actually
the point is to remove the knight from
defending the pawn
even though this pawn is kind of pinned
to the rook
i take the pawn i hit the queen
and if this or this takes i have this
move
with the battery skewer thing
some potential
hello kebabs elton khan's
new time sub
oh to be a with a first time chat
subs before they chatted
go roses for tuning
no mercy
no mercy
no mercy with the arrows
there's a line uh bishop c6 i take the
knight
i lose a rook
but then i take the bishop
and
yeah that looks pretty good for me
because i have two minor pieces for
a rook
maybe black or white would win a couple
pawns
the white's probably going to be losing
on time
very soon
pb bulltok welcome back
subbing for 18 months
[Music]
um i want to do things here
i want to play this move
looks like a cool move
instead of taking the rook
i hit the bishop and if takes i take one
year
introducing my students to kung fu chess
through one of your videos today they
are big fans of yours oh nice to hear
i hope they don't they don't get too
addicted
okay appointment was a little bit too
slow i think the final position
is probably much better for black
oh much better for white
i play too recklessly
i thought it was going to be winning
material but
i guess white has good compensation here
fe3
yeah this pawn is hard to win
okay back to tournament
so that was the first game
[Music]
uh ooh
wait what
oh
i had another tattletail that's berserk
and e4
i'm going to turn off pentatonic
i don't want to fall
asleep again
we have an elephant gambit
i haven't encountered the elephant in uh
a while
i think but nice e4
i actually don't know theory here i'm
gonna play knight c4
hey eric thank you for existing love all
your chess content
oh thank you
grimer
i appreciate your existence as well
good luck for the arena oh thanks so
much for being awesome
i really want to play this move
uh let's do it
i'm berserk in this game
um it calls for some
aggressive
maybe slightly dubious chess
i just want to open each file
and uh
eventually checkmates
so there's a line uh takes takes knight
g4
but then i have bishop e2
which
like pretty much traps in knight
or maybe it doesn't
oh
[Music]
okay let's take a pawn
because g5 was hanging um
queen was attacking
this is really risky though
play this move
so i'm down a piece and i'm like
uncastled and pinned
but
at the same time
i feel like i'm pretty close to mating
because i'm ready to castle queenside
even ready to play a move like queen h3
wow queen g5
i wonder if i can play 93 here
it's a really confusing position
so 93
a lot of things just happened after this
move i'm hitting the knight but i also
unpinned this knight
so i'm hitting the queen
and i have a still a decent amount of
attacking potential and i want to castle
queenside
wow
uh
before
b4 is probably no good
you just c3
oh i want to do things
i have to take
i think we'll have to wait
even the move like knight f6 check
is really interesting
takes and then takes
then takes in king d2
i mean visually it looks really good
because the king is completely naked
and i i'm controlling all the squares
around the king
rook h8 is an a threat
there's two checks but then after king
d2
rook takes e3 maybe king f1
yeah because there's a line uh this this
this and if take so it's queen f5
okay
so the riskiness paid off i was probably
objectively much worse acting
uh
oh we already have the computer analysis
yeah um
but okay
one in 20 moves
thank you saluki
okay so the goal is to break into the
top
two thousand that's the first goal
hey saluki
sharing a hundred bits and then a
thousand bits appreciate that
um i'll be right again
mix up the openings a little bit
bishop g7
yeah normally this this is not a great
development scheme for block
but
um
it's not always easy to punish
just a matter of
developing harmoniously
okay i'm uh
i'm trying to unleash my inner mama
tiara
the early g4
position is already crumbling for back
um also yeah hello to so many people
um
also thank you to those who
cheered or subbed who i didn't
discovered my favorite name for an
opening ooh the whale the web c4 e5 e4
oh
i didn't know that was
that was called the whale
because that would
that would kind of be like a baffinic
english
okay it feels like christmas
uh
winning a lot of material here
it's that time of year already
super sugar
it is yeah it's a yearly early blitz
arena
i think i've played this in previous
years too
[Music]
okay where's my meat
uh
okay i'm gonna try and set up f3
checkmates
so here here and then threatening this
this and mate
hey it's gonna happen
always play f3 checkmate
okay that was pleasant
next game
closing in on top 1000
thanks again super sugar
71 mb3r
oh solid 73 with a sub f3 f3 quack quack
okay let's dessert again
[Music]
yeah or always play f3 and it might be
mate
oh what's up hoga shout out to akash
okay so
i have a pretty pleasant position
just similar structures to the previous
game
but the previous game i went for this
early like g4 push
this game
it's going to be a bit more positional
i have some idea of taking and
doing things maybe this oh it's not
blender and knight
play this move
usually the knights here and then
i could play this move
i play this there's b4
okay so
yeah the plan is to gradually expand the
center
the e5 is probably the main goal
[Music]
so bishop f6
threatening e5
a5 queen b7
c5 is another idea
i think this works
this could just lead to a train
i'm
i think i'm getting the bishop hair
whoa it's la la laney
gifting 10. i appreciate that
thank you la la lanie
thank you aguerio
pine guy didn't get a notification
um
who got notification there there had to
be some people right
sometimes it's just a matter of enabling
notifications
i know some people just like have my
twitch
channel open
so that whenever i go live they'll just
be here
automatically
oh maybe sometimes people get
notifications late too
take a while for all of them to go out
yeah there's also discord notifications
as well for for twitch and youtube
tony was watching and i am rose and on
twitch
and got notification
i i guess i'm competing with my past
self for
some people's attention
okay so hitting the queen in the pawn
queen doesn't have too many squares once
i take the pawn then the knight will be
skewered and pinned
and bishop will be vulnerable too
wow wow quack
welcome back hsw
yeah i think white's in big trouble here
okay
it's starting pretty smoothly
1023
um
[Music]
i should make a goal
i'm probably going to play the rest of
the tournament so
i think top 10 is a reasonable goal
top five may be a bit more ambitious but
it's doable if i can stay sharp
try and stay clean too
consuming your videos therapeutically
love them so much thank you less than
three oh i appreciate that
thank you
jonathan
oh does the merch code still work even
though it's wednesday
uh
it does i forgot to disable it so people
can still take advantage of the
uh the tuesday coupon code
what to do here bishop c4 is reasonable
knight b6 bishop b3
that's already like difficult for about
queen e7 is uh
um
like a common mistake
because it blocks a bishop it slows down
development
it still takes work to
get a sizeable advantage
okay hitting the pawn
plugging the rose and discord hashtag
code channel a surprisingly high quality
community of programmers and the reason
i'm finally learning rust oh that's
awesome
[Music]
hello everyone
yeah there's some channels i mean i'm
i'm already like not so active on
discord but uh
i know there's a nice community and
there's a lot of different channels too
so
yeah link is in the chat for
for discord
can i take a knight d5
i think i'll start with rook
start with this move
utilize open vials
and take a knight d5
not sure if i'm actually winning
anything though like 26
calculating um 26 knight c7 queen e5
knight a6 takes takes and i'm
threatening mate there's queen d5 in the
end
but then queen or queen f7 i get mated
or i lose a queen
oh f7 is wait no
oh wait b6 is hanging
yeah i was expecting queen e6 to
like keep things defended
okay should defend
there's a sneaky move rook a6
which i couldn't play last move because
h2 is hanging but now i can play it
and now the point is i'm threatening
made in one and if black takes a rook
it's still made in one
[Music]
so it's a question will the rook or the
queen
checkmate on eight
i don't think that can stop it
actually maybe black can stop it
but it's not going to be pretty for
black
this position is uh is very nice
there is some people say in chat
noise
oh it's jane galt
oh jane gold is the creator of uh
chess
also quack
so just so you know trophies have
changed
or wait no
wait i i got confused i thought you were
i miss red
change the face of chess
i guess people can accumulate rose and
trophies by
playing these uh suspicious openings
[Music]
wait what am i doing here
yeah bishop c5 was a good move
um
i guess i'm winning
am i winning a piece
it's close to mating now
yeah we have a rosen score command
i was sharing this website the other day
i'm not sure if the the creator of the
site
is present in chat
okay that was a
a nice finish
given i was running kind of low on time
oh thank you berlin
it's loving for 14 months
yeah here's a
maybe i'll come back to the site at a
later point
i love you eric
oh i love you too
robert
okay i'm insisting on stafford
uh let's play this move
okay already uh pretty nice opening
success
well i could take the pawn
the problem for white is
the king is a bit stuck because there's
no castling queen side
and the bishop is completely blocked in
we might see g3
another five i might just take
in king f8
oh we have not had any troxers yet
um
this is my first game with the e4 e5 as
black
oh what to do
and queen g5
setting up a trap if
like castles i have queen e3 takes take
slamming the knight
and if king h1 i take the knight i lose
f7 and
everything's okay
wow queen enough too
oh maybe i'm not winning anything
i'm not winning anything here
knight t7
or maybe c6
i'm leaving tension
i'm waiting for the knight to move back
for bishop e3
white's playing well though
the white's playing very carefully
knight five's a good move
i should not have allowed knight five
oh what to do
in this move
hey what's up irene
i burned a lot of time this game
ah the other night's coming to f5
i'll undevelop the bishop
and then
let's defend the pawn
now the good thing is i'm i'm still up a
pawn
but my structure is a little bit ugly
let's play
f6
always play f6
if i can get a knight to e5 i'll be
happy
yeah white should have probably tried to
get a rook in sooner
[Music]
bishop b3 i'll play c5
or maybe no need maybe king f7 rook g8
writing this
okay plenty of time
where's my mates
okay
yeah i feel a little bit rusty but uh so
far so good
dessert winning all the games
except the first game i did in berserk
top 500.
let's go
oh thank you earlier to dr davey
sobbing for two months
derek bananas
the prime sub
all right i'll keep it
going um
just for joe who was asking earlier oh
never mind
i wanted to play a traxxar
let's play a schliemann
i haven't played the schliemann in a
while
oh no heart rate i i can actually turn
on the heart rate monitor
um
if i can find it
yeah it's usually just a matter of me
opening the app on my watch
it connects to some app which
um
there we go
yeah it's set up with uh
with like a stream
like browser source
hey below 60.
i wonder what my lowest heart rate has
been on stream
queen e2
i don't remember in my theory here
i think it's this
move it takes takes d4 bishop g7 takes
castling
or there's some weird line
i went through a very brief phase of
playing the schliemann
uh this f5 opening in tournament play
this was back when i was
rated around 2200.
i used to watch the um it was called
it's a series of videos
relaxing mf stream but not been watching
on youtube for a couple years
oh welcome og puddin pop
so before the days of like chess on
youtube
i would watch
these video series on icc
the internet chess club
and there's a series called gambit guide
by
boris alterman
grandmaster and he made like
probably a 15 to 20 hour series
maybe ten maybe five to ten hour series
on
uh on the shemen
and that's where i learned most of my
theory
okay so we have an interesting position
it's um the material imbalance
i have
two minor pieces for rook and jupines
okay so i unpin this pawn
also after takes takes i'll be hitting
f2
pull on pentatonic for 5 bpm dip
i wonder would pentatonic like decrease
my heart rate
can i get below 50
okay i'll put on pentatonic
my heart rate might go up though because
i'm getting low on time
to take a deep breath
i wanted to take take take but there was
queen c4 check winning the bishop
oh although i had to queen d5
i think the bishop's a bit better on d6
[Music]
gifting 5 subs if you get your heart
rate below 50 bpm
oh
that makes me more nervous
now it's above 60.
it's not going to happen this game
i have 50 seconds left
i do have the bishop hair
bishop pair should help me relax
i'm funny like queen h4 g3 bishop g3
been watching your stuff on youtube for
over a year now great stuff
oh thank you
quasi chaser
akd thanks for gifting five
so i'm threatening mate and g3 uh bishop
g3
is a funny tactic
because takes takes and bishop is saved
[Music]
okay
the rook's tied down to the pawn
[Music]
finding this
maybe this was better actually
[Music]
rookie seven of rick g6 winning the rook
the backwards discovery
oh akd gifting 5 subs for the heart
beating at whatever rate
that's an easier challenge to accomplish
we just have to stay alive
you're writing this
[Music]
hey
gifting five thank you heavenism
that king's very safe with bishop on e7
this pawn is probably gonna fall very
soon
or not
this is g6
mate um
[Music]
time scramble time
it's a very relaxing time scramble
actually
okay
yeah usually when there's time scrambles
my heart rates
will
sometimes go above 100 but
not this time
i missed 500 free rooks yeah i know
actually i didn't know
back to tournaments
okay
um
let's move on let's play e4
so i'm gonna play
c6
i'll play d4
i was ready to play a grand prix attack
i'll still play aggressively
[Music]
hmm
take with queen i lose a pawn
this looks nice though
a bit more development
okay after this game i'll turn off
pentatonic
because i do want to stay awake
yeah let's open the position
temporary funny pawns
i'm smelling tactics but i'm not seeing
tactics
i have to work on my senses
queen d2 maybe
just very simple improving
so i'm stacking f3 but
i just want a castle and made on d8s
maybe it's tacos
tacos
oh yesterday was taco tuesday
i didn't have any tacos
it's actually been a long time since
i've had a taco
yeah this is what we call superfluous
nights
now i want tacos oops
this is what happens when i hold down
the z key
i'm toggling zen mode
and this is what happens when i hold
down the f key
okay let's stop doing that
f is useful though because you can
[Music]
get a better sense of how the opponent
is feeling
uh take a pawn
[Music]
no need to take the knight too soon
f7 is a task
oh
i really want to sack my queen for meat
um
okay i'll start with this
i wanted to take and then do this but
the king would
eventually run
so here here i take the knight with
check
and i'll be up a piece
wow queen b7
[Music]
okay
upper queen
and down a little bit of time but uh
yeah it's plenty of time for this
position
and if rook takes rook i'll take with
king
because the knight is pinned and it
can't be defended
and there's one check that kings he won
this pond's been hanging for a while
rook d3 would be an interesting move
because maybe some players would
pre-move queen f3
[Music]
i can play this and say oh no my bishop
and then mate
i have to be a little bit careful
[Music]
oh no i'm getting pinned
yeah the bishop is pinned to
the b7 square basically
not that it matters so much
okay
uh
yeah that was a nice game
got some nice uh nice attacking position
from the opening
i was i wanted to be fancy here like
take take and then check king d7
but i didn't see made in that line
okay back to tournaments
top 300
35 tournament points
a leader has 105
yeah sergey is giga one of the top
players on the chest
i forgot to
stop brewing my tea
i'm making a new type of tea today
you can see this
it's uh
it's watermelon cooler
berserking's dangerous um
against someone over 2200
that's not t those are cubes
yeah uh
i think it's like it's a mix of like
apple pieces and some watermelon
goodness
some rose hips
okay we'll have a very symmetrical
position
oh let me trim off pentatonic
yeah thank you clutch spork
one clutch spork
gifted sub
um
i think this is okay
this is usually the idea of like the
early g pawn push
i'll take with knight
um
what to do here
h5 there's f5 maybe
a queen d7
f6 is covered by the knight i do have to
be careful when playing this move
because there's triple fork potential
queenside castling
and i really want to
start doing things
d4 is actually a good move
um
g4 is a really good move
i'm probably in a bit of trouble here
takes
i'm actually in a lot of trouble here
i think i'm just losing a piece actually
i have to focus
it might be too late though
[Music]
i'm flagging too
oh no
[Music]
okay the plan is to do this and sack and
hope it's meat
sack everything it might be checkmate
okay hitting e4 now
good move
yeah i'm getting just fully punished
for my recklessness
white's played well though
hitting this pawn
and queen g4 may be coming
let me hear this move
turning the bishop
queen g4 there was rook h4
it was defended by the queen
um
ah i tried the still me trick it didn't
work though
oh no my heart rate
okay first loss
yeah i got way too long time that game
and too low on material
but that's part of life
life goes on
yeah i couldn't force a stalemate there
i mean
i had to be somewhat hopeful
okay uh time for carol khan
so
black is actually walking into
a uh
it's like one of the
most common traps
that amateur players walk into in this
line
um which i covered in my how to crush
the caro khan video
most people play bishop h7 after which
queenie tribe is very strong
always fun watching you eric much love
lll
thanks for the love
l for love
epoch 44 welcome back
thank you ice cream sunday
okay pleasant position
i didn't win any any material but uh
yeah the queens have been misplaced
h5 or bishop d3 will come with tempo
[Music]
okay so officially less than three hours
to go
i had the goal earlier of top ten
which is probably still pretty ambitious
but
i'm going to try
wow f5
hello chat
oh hello oh pbr
welcome back
okay so i'm attacking the bishop but i'm
also
i was also attacking the pawn but
black defends
oh there's a funny mate
involving a queen sack it could happen
in the next like three or four moves
or not
i'm waiting for black to castle
queenside
there's also a funny queen trap i'm
finding this this and then bishop h5
there we go
yeah the funny mate was if uh
black could castled and
i would go for the i think it's called
the bowden's mate
um how do i save the night
i'm just losing the night i have this
move
i guess i'm winning a pawn
it looks awkward though
yeah bishop h6 was probably the wrong
decision
this move
still trying to save my knight
it's never a blunder it's a gambit yeah
we have to treat every
every blunder as a gambit
what is going on here
i like gambit all my time
okay i'll take here
um black's actually fighting back very
creatively
but there's this pin so i have a pretty
strong attack still
okay threatening this
rook g7
g7 almost drops my queen
i'd have to play queen a5
oh no
okay
it's a gambit
it's a gambit
i have to give my opponent a false sense
of security
actually i'm i'm kind of trapping the
bishop
i'm also meeting okay
i'm i'm living up to the quote on this
mug
that was such a bad
game overall
i want a queen that i proceeded to
blunder most of my pieces
but then i made it so
it's a happy ending
okay
i i didn't gather any rating there
thankfully
oh this is
playing liam 64.
so we have a london turned into
a queen's gambit type thing
play queen b3
maybe h3 some g4 idea
yeah maybe a4 wasn't the best move there
the pawn would like to go backwards but
it's too late
on the bright side this bishop is uh
it's a really
unfortunate piece
although e5 yeah okay so things are
going to open up
i do have the bishop hair
wow
d4 d4 is a good move actually
um
i'm a little bit pinned
okay there's a funny line rook d one
[Music]
and if it takes i'll play knight e4
and takes i take with rook
and i'd be hitting the queen and the
knight
and i'll play knight
knight f3
a confusing position now
it's also bishop f3
yeah the bishop's well placed here
and after it takes
i probably just take back
i have slightly weird pawn structure but
have some files
wow okay six
okay let's take this
yeah so i'm opening up the queen
i'm also controlling this d6 square
ideology 496
or bishop d6
okay forking coming
quintuple fork
these things don't matter as much as
these things
about a lot of targets in black's
position
[Music]
rookie 7 is probably most likely
ooh
okay so i'm obstructing the queen from
defending the pawn
um
the goal is to win the pawn at some
point
see all these ponds are potential
weaknesses
interesting move
i think bishop f7 would have trapped my
queen there
like crazy move
i still have to be careful with my queen
on the edge
um bishop c6 i think i'm winning a
knight
yeah thankfully g6 didn't drop my queen
if black stocks on f3 i'm gonna win g6
at some point
okay threatening this
i'm threading rook f8 mate
yeah i should have played rook f7 in the
first place
okay
i should go back and show
i'm pretty sure like i i would have been
in big trouble this game
um
after queen h5
it's like kind of out of nowhere looks
like my queen has squares but
there's about seven
i just have no squares for the queen
yeah like only winning move too
okay that was close
uh let's go top 200
back on a streak
i'm playing alan triple five
let's work again
berserking's okay as long as i
like stay focused and manage my time
oh no my knight
it's a funny opening line actually this
bishop takes e4 and there's d5
and black wins back a piece
this one i think knight
just goes back
threatening e4
i'll admit i don't know lunch theory
here but i assume this is
this is okay for black
because i defend the pawn i break the
pin
white could take either way i'll take
back with bishop
thank you kristoff
my first time rhyme sub
haven't scanned it next game
[Music]
um
yeah i'll keep mixing it up between e4
and
d4 next theme i probably do for d4
or up for e4
but i still need to learn some evidence
gamma theory
um
yeah five here
yeah i don't think i'll be playing a
bongo this tournament
unless i get like heavily bribed
okay time is looking pretty good this
game
i'm already down less than two minutes
hmm
so white's going for trades
i'm really tempted to play this move
which is a it's a temporary pawn sack
this takes
uh like could take the pawn
but then bishop f5 and i'll win back
some stuff
bishop e3 is probably more likely
um
or that move
so if white takes twice i i mate in the
end
and bishop e3 i'll keep the bishop here
oh what's your favorite gambit i mean
uh staffer gambit by far
but after after stafford
maybe boo the past budapest can be
pretty fun
which is maybe a bit strange because uh
i i prefer gambits for black over
cabinets per white
am i losing a pawn
i might be winning it back though
actually it's complicated
i think i'm just losing a pawn
the good thing is white's kind of weak
in the light squares
so um and i have lights for bishop
i'm probably threatening rook g7
[Music]
now the move i wanted to play
okay how does whites oh it just defends
like that
that bishop three
i think the knight is trapped
only move is knight a7
and then king b8
and i'm threatening this
i control c6 with the bishop
and i'm up on time
okay good things are happening here
and i'm winning this pawn
okay
maybe not the cleanest game but
got the job done
still striving for top 100
[Music]
playing mazdi
oh
it's a what is this
i play this move
and d4 it takes takes
it's like a
reverse fried liver
but with c4 included it should be good
because there's no c3
it's a weird opening
um
i want to play this move knight e3 but
let's be sane
thank you atticus
oh it's a whale
ah this is a whale
oh what do i do
probably
a5 all hail the whale
maybe this move
hail the whale
yeah
yeah brazilian was mentioning the whale
earlier
oh
not sure this is winning
it looks close to winning
i wanted to play this but after it takes
our b bishop to h3
i'm going whale hunting this game
will hunting or real fishing
whales aren't really fish
also that's probably frowned upon in
most places right
hmm where's my mate
i have to move the knight
i don't want to move the knight
call him ishmael
oh super illegal okay
but as long as i'm playing legal moves
hopefully i'm staying within the
[Music]
the realm of the law
so i'm hitting both nights with this
move i'm more interested in winning this
night
because it's preventing me from mating
in two
okay there goes the whale
okay hey top 100 let's go 51 points
zhigalco has over 100
119
but making progress
please play danish gambit
your wish is my command
danish candid time
c2
now c2 i don't think is so common i mean
it's one way of declining the second
pawn
but now i'm only down one pawn
and
yeah i'm feeling pretty good here e5
nice thing about danish is
if black even just accepts one pawn
it leads to really nice development lead
for white
and it's going to be hard for black to
complete development
bishop g5 probably coming
yeah i don't want a queen trade here
um
if i play this there's 95
knight g6 might be coming
i think i can probably just harass the
queen
like queen c5 bishop e3
queen a5 b4
queen a4 i trapped the queen
the queen might just be getting trapped
here actually
or i'll like win a thing
yeah 95
[Music]
i could take the queen but
i'm thinking queen e4
and the the black queen is still
ah but the knight of three check
i want to take on f7 but
i don't think that works
i'll take
okay so black
black kind of survived that
and now we have a
slightly strange material imbalance
i have an extra bishop but black has
three pawns for it
i don't know what to do
in this move
if c6 i'll play bishop c5
okay now i know what to do
oh
yeah box been resourceful this game
but now i'm winning back some pawns
knight moves i have bishop g6
if knight doesn't move i i win the night
also thank you earlier to
their socksy
another new prime sub
okay this is made in
three okay danish gamma's success
thanks to whoever suggested that
that was a huge menses
it was a very timely opening request
thank you
kept winning
i'll do my best
so i've lost one game this tournament
but uh
yeah overall
things have been pretty good so far
i'll keep berserking too
okay evans gabit time
this is a request from earlier from joe
i don't know if joe is still here but
i hope you're happy joe
oh joe is still here okay
um
yeah i have no idea like evan's gambit
theory
i think this is a line
all i know is you're supposed to sack
stuff and then check me at the king
okay this is working out really nicely
uh where's the meat
there's probably not me here
oh no my bishop
i meant to play this as a mouse slip
i think i think ben is realizing if pawn
digs bishop it's made in one
so where is my mate
oh no i'm getting triple forked
okay
uh
i mean it seems like mate is close but
but no
cigar i have this move
just preventing any knight e5
shenanigans
there's a funny line now if uh if black
takes the bishop i'm not meeting but i
would still be making this work h3
okay let's
let's just trade
i'm up a whole rook here or no i'm off a
whole exchange
for a pawn
maybe i could have gone more but uh
okay it's working out
try and use my kingside pawns
bishop d5 is a resource
probably threatening rook b1
these all these things are a bit tender
i might play g3 just to
over defend the pawn to mobilize her
rook
it's hard to find a move here for that
because night's kind of pinned to both
pawns
and the bishops tied down to defending
the knight
yeah i think i'm just winning a pawn
here
rook video i have roxy savannah
ooh
there's bishop c6 which is almost kind
of clever
but then rook c8
[Music]
i just want to defend the pawn maybe
i'll push the pawn
okay so
now i'm up a full rook
plenty of time
if kim g5 uh there's a funny mate
there would have been king here here and
then
[Music]
some eventual mates
[Music]
so
thank you the ultimate potser
solving for 20 months
okay um
i know there's been predictions running
i'm gonna request that ahmad
made one last prediction
of whether i'll finish in the top five
and top five is my goal it's gonna be
difficult but uh
i think maybe it's doable
actually i'll make the prediction
oh we have
a poll going too
actually i won't make that prediction
because
i need to focus on the game
okay i'll play this g5 line again
the one game i lost this tournament
was in this uh
this g5
italian
but it was slightly different
yeah for those that don't know rosen
trophies
uh it's referring to the
the rosen score website and we do have a
rosen score command
if you want to find out how many rows
and trophies you have
uh what to do here
and take and reach
okay i'm liking uh liking the position
things have simplified a little bit
now there's there's a lot of pressure on
the king side
[Music]
looking at this move
yeah because takes takes queen d2
i was looking at bishop f3
there's also bishop
h3 um
yeah might as well be material
okay this rook wants to enter the game
i'm thinking the king is safest on f8
if a bishop d5 i do have c6
going for h4 very soon
i can take the bishop because uh
queen has to defend the rook
queen f4 looks pretty straightforward so
after takes takes all
i'll win the g3 pawn
[Music]
that looks a little bit awkward
though the king can't really do much
damage
actually everything here is untouchable
so basically what i can do is just march
march up the king in the pawn
i think everything's a safe free move
um
okay
another rating point gained
top 40.
yeah prediction's still going so
uh
wow most people don't think i'll finish
top five
look at this what is this
there's so many doubters
i feel so inspired now
almost a million channel points on no
okay
i probably shouldn't have deserved this
opponent
but too late now
oh it's not a poll it's a prediction
they're slightly different
i think i'm throwing e5
never mind
i'm actually not thrilled with uh this
position
you go for c4
okay resembles some like hedgehog
sicilian
ivan rozzi mine set up
probably bishop c3 coming
e5 ideas
and there's cases where the bishop might
want to go back to f1
an event of knight e5
although 85 i went upon
[Music]
okay things are getting spicy now
hitting the knight but there's some
x-ray vision against the queen
there's another five ideas
just preventing any d4 shenanigans
position actually looks really nice
i maybe could have played queen f4 there
so i want to unpin and threaten to take
the knight
interesting
we trade
i can win a pawn but i don't know if i
want to win a pawn
deciding not to
i think the attack is more valuable
it's still queen f4 queen g4 ideas
if g6 i'm in this pawn
and see if i have a b1
i'm allowing g5 but
it could get really messy
also along this move
what's going on
turning on the f7 pawn
also hitting the knight
oh
my blunder
[Music]
i think i've laundered
um
what to do
yeah this is a big trouble
i'm sure i missed something somewhere
yeah there goes all my pieces
well played to my opponent
i have three seconds left
yeah no still mates
okay
what to do there is a cool line
um
[Music]
i wanted to play e6 maybe i should have
to set up this i just wasn't sure that
it takes
because then g7 would be defended
let's see wow plus seven
oh nine h6 first
and then this with check
yeah
okay
tough game
um
so my goal's top five
which requires
oh that requires a lot of winning
okay
because i have 60 tournament points
i think top 10 is
it maybe a more realistical
but some people in chat maybe believe
i don't know why i'm observing now it's
reflexive
oh this tilts okay
let's say the tilt is setting in but
uh let's take
let's play a hippo
it's interesting position
g2 there's some x-ray vision
uh that's a good move
if i take
i have to move the rook
i want to play this
yeah i'd prevent it on poissant
let's create a triple battery
good luck in the tournament
great content as always
so much
mr potato
or mr pitou
welcome back
there we go
[Music]
there's no wind
um
oh that was a bad move
this bishop f3
okay
oh the pawn can't be stopped
there we go
okay got the job done
i'm sure there was something a bit
easier there oh just rook g2 i can see
the thing was hanging
g2 was defended for so long
okay
got the job done though
all right
um
i think i have to deserve to
try and maximize my score
it's risky though
so i defend the bishop i want to take
back with the knight
of this move
i know this is a crazy line
i'm not so thoroughly prepared
like takes i take on c6
um
maybe just this
check
threatening this now
really oh queen d5
queen d5 queen b3
threatening rook t1
some bishop f3 in the error
okay so king b i have queen g3 chuck
bishop c5
maybe he's still queen g3
should probably castle though
uh queen g3
i might be throwing e3 and b4
depending where the king moves
[Music]
i cover d2
keep defending the knight the bishop is
pinned so there's no bishop f2
i'm still threatening discoveries as
well
[Music]
wow
knight g5 after rook f8
because after it takes i take and win
both pieces
i'm also threatening a triple fork
so this move in itself is a fork
threatening the knight triple fork
and the pawn
a cool game
thank you nico timba
the prime sub
okay
yeah just rook
yeah rookie 3 i think is simple enough
there we go
hey hey it's hikaru what's up hikaru
i appreciate the raid
if you're just joining i'm
i'm playing chess
it's kind of like chessel but
with actual chess pieces
shout out to hikaru
yeah i would love to say hi to everyone
specifically
um
[Music]
but i don't want a flag i don't want a
blunder either
yeah trying to grind down
what's the best strategy here
win a pawn make a queen
or just trade brooks
i'd be careful for like stale matrix
hi to eric specifically
oh hi to jack tiggs specifically
uh oh no my rook
okay that was a fancy way to simplify
oh it's almost like the ending just
searching for bobby fischer
but not quite alternative ending
okay
yeah welcome everyone
i appreciate all the energy
so yeah for those joining uh this is a
yearly blitz arena it happens once a
year
i late joined
um it's a six hour tournament
i joined
two hours late but i'm trying to finish
as high as possible
my goal is top five
which might be difficult but
um
okay back on the streak
lost two games so far did i miss maiden
one
did i actually miss maiden one
uh
it's too late now okay
uh
let's try and get a staffer gambit
staff or gambit time it's the first
stafford of the stream
don't hurt me
i actually i like it when white starts
thinking in this position
this clear light uh maybe isn't super
well prepared
yeah so with h3 that prevents knight g4
but uh now we go into this line
and
white house be really careful in this
line
because there's some idea in a g4
king h1
i think still knight g4
because f2 is less defended everything
made in one
if takes takes uh
the file opens and i'm still mating
if f4i i go in for the fork
um
don't play this but there's knight e2
i'll do it anyway queen h4
ooh
[Music]
i take
i don't think it works
i wanted to take but 92
nice thing is i'm up on time
and not material
and
white has a big center
let's play this move
white's actually playing this well
i don't feel like i'm getting so much
initiative
as long as the center can liquify
[Music]
the problem is this bishop is just it's
not involved
so i think the way to make it involves
is to play this and this
ooh
and this move
[Music]
yeah i'm realizing d5 is just uh
it's annoying move
okay that worked out nicely
good game pompous clunker
okay top 30.
let's go 77 points
um
yeah less than two hours left chicago
has 145
so i have slightly less than
half as many points as jigall go
grandmaster burr
this is uh out of zoria
okay because working continues
so i'll transpose into a some sort of
appearance
i'm going for quick aggression
wait 77
oh i can't do math it's slightly more
than half of chicago
i was thinking 144 but it's 154
um
[Music]
h4 maybe just h3
usually h4 is a go-to move
on h4
it's a little bit weakening to the
square but
eventually i'll play f3 maybe g4
i might play queen d6 just make it
positional
hmm
okay so if b5 i think i get away with
taking
meanwhile i just want to like dominate
the d file
let's play this
so if a3 then b4
[Music]
here i'm just doing a pawn
am i winning more
a pawn is good enough i might be
actually winning two pawns
a4 hangs
when knight takes i have rook d7
yeah b4
i should have played b3
uh where's the mate
in this move
idea rook d3
it's kind of passive but
i just want to win the pawn
the black wants to win my pawn
so i'll bring the king to b3
um
a it's a fork
there's knight b6 but then rook b8 rogue
a6 b5
i guess there's c4
maybe i just take
i'm taking is way more simple
and check and win the night
yeah i have a lot of pawns here
so i'm setting up a classic mating idea
f6 and rook g7
yeah this is not stalemate
okay let's go
thank you quail king
subbing for half a year
okay 21st place
so we did have a prediction earlier
whether i'll finish top five
and most people think i won't
so
i have to prove the doubters wrong
another double wizard game
hmm
and just g6
or maybe not maybe 96
or queen
queen h4
i'm so indecisive
so i hit the bishop
and the this tactic doesn't work because
i have 96.
same thing with queen queen d5 probably
96.
they called like windy for
just offer queen trade
after it takes takes and i hit c2
okay so we're getting some weird like
queenless middle game
i'm a little bit stuck with the queen
side development
but becoming less stuck
okay much less stuck here
and sometimes it's not easy to win a
position like this
um
oh no my sub
oh yes your sub
thank you sponge like cannon
yeah so time is a very important factor
here
time and patience i should
probably should have taken the pawn
okay
opponent really wants to draw i have
this move now
there's an endgame situation where we
trade off uh lightweight bishops and
rooks
yeah and then i play a4
so i'm fixing the pawns and dark squares
uh let's not plunder upon
[Music]
have to play this
on the surface this looks draws but
black has a
a substantial
edge here just because the pawns are
fixed on dark squares
um it might still objectively be drawn
but it's going to be difficult for white
to play
a decision to make
i think this move
so i'm threading this
you might have to like move something
yeah the pawns are just too weak for
white
there's a funny maid of bishop here and
some meat
all of white's pawns were falling that
was pleasant
a nice uh nice kind of endgame strategy
there
so 87 tournament points
um still takes a lot of work to
work my way into the top 10.
any tips for improving my reading
um
don't worry about like increasing your
rating just
focus on improving your understanding of
chess and have a growth mindset try and
learn something from every game
especially your losses but also your
wins
and as uh
as your understanding of chess improves
so so will your rating
sometimes it takes time for your reading
to
reflect your understanding so
patience is important
but uh
yeah a lot of people get fixated on
rating when uh
what's most important is that you
you enjoy the journey
um
losing a pawn here
i think we're both gonna be casting
queenside
this pawn is very tender
oh
i thought that was winning the pawn but
i guess not
knight d5
i'm king b1
it's a slow move but
some prophylaxis so i hit the queen
i'm bishop e2
bishop v2
the pawn is still tender
and it's actually a very nice like
positional game here
because white has better structure
uh interesting move
there's knight c6 check
i can't get away with taking it
black is
fighting but i'm also fighting
okay now i have a passport
uh looks like black is just going
a little bit crazy
as long as i'm not getting needed
um
thanks for subbing
you don't even know it
i'm still struggling to win this
okay
got the job done there
it's difficult to stay like focused and
alert
a whole game
but i have a nice streak going
i lost to this opponent earlier
maybe not this tournament though
okay
now we have the first budapest gamut of
the stream
um
now this thing earlier this is probably
my second favorite gamut behind the
stafford
because even in a position like this it
does offer
black some nice attacking chances
also some nice retreating chances
yeah this is a typical budapest idea
queen
age four
another five i take the pawn
i want to play rook here upon here
got all the things involved
ooh
someone buying merch
nice shirt i had to have one [ __ ]
uh
i want to play this move
i don't think it works
um
okay
i'm mission aborted
i might go for this and then still this
and it looks so wrong though
thank you
la baguette cocky
i do appreciate the subs
and doughnos and
all the support ooh
[Music]
um
[Music]
a very tricky move
is a really funny idea
i don't know if it works but i'm gonna
i'm gonna go for it rook h3
so it looks like rogue age one was
unstoppable but now i'm hitting the
knight
i'm just not sure about this line like
bishop f4 knight g6
takes takes
king f3
and also take this way maybe
wow
what's going on
does it mean
four one two or mean three
queen h5 bishop e3 meet
wow
that worked out nicely
i wasn't expecting the rook to just land
on
[Music]
uh
or the the kingdom land on f4
i did miss uh rookie three here too
but
i didn't even consider rookie three
because i saw the force mate in another
line okay uh that worked out nicely
berserk win with the budapest
15th place
the berserking street continues
thank you talon factory
okay it's berserk
and try and get another stafford
okay opponent falls into this uh
a very basic trap
already very difficult position because
the king can't castle either way
probably queen
25 with the battery
king d2 probably has to be played
that move i can win the pawn
[Music]
might as well
i'll throw in queen c3 check
for the giggles
at rook b1 i do have a queen
queen d4
maybe in this move
because i want to just clamp down on the
d4 square
and the plan is probably c5
was my plan
c5 rookie at f5
in combination with b6a5
yeah white has nothing on the queen side
and now this pawn is a weakness
bishop d7 ideas
have a similar game earlier where
yeah in end games where
each side has a bishop of a certain
color
you want your pawns on the off the color
of the bishops
so white's not really following that
rule
and still takes some work to win
but now f5
yeah so this is weakness this is
weakness
how to do this
i just want to get a pawn cube
oh
let's move
okay no more fooling around let's just
push pawns
oh
[Music]
am i in trouble
i think i'm okay
the reason i didn't see that coming
i have this move
this is not intended
don't hurt me
thankfully i have a nice time advantage
it's a funny line
okay so now it's a queen ending
oh let's advance
check
okay one on time
not the cleanest finish but
as a finish nonetheless
hey over 100 tournament points
14th place
top five requires yeah requires still a
lot of work
also just 90 minutes to go
93 minutes to go
i have more space but uh any point black
can get the bishop here
i think the plan in the position like
this is just like gradually
improve like 92 c3
i even go for h4 at some point
hey thank you niku
do you have any romanian friends
i do
i was in romania
uh
i went to romania two years in a row
in
was 2017 and 2018.
i played the fisca open
it was in the town of jupiter
rather than the planet
um
there's a few romanian chess players
or players in the us from romania
christian carrillo
who's probably like very well known in
romania also sabina foyser
and i'm yeah i'm friendly with both of
them
uh oh let's go
let's go for this
i'm waiting for the day
black takes on g3
so then i can take back and
get a nike f5
or knife to f5
oh i want to do things
e5
e5 doesn't work
queen f4 is interesting
i think i'll play queen f4
yeah they'd used to take
it might get weird
the king could move
they excited win the bishop
the king moves i have queen f5
there's funny line king d7 queen f5
takes on an e5
okay now the bishop is pinned to the
pawn
what are the odds
when he moved knight c8
doesn't really do much though
i think the main threat is e5
another idea in the f7 and then e5
unleashing the battery
okay so
yeah we can trade
g3
restrict the knight defend the pawn
i'll bring the knight to f1
[Music]
so another idea of knife f5
b4
actually
i'll go for night uh
i wanted to play knight f4
it looks like i'm winning upon the end
am i maybe i'm not
oh but maybe i am
and king takes was maybe a bit better
if i'm down on time but it probably
won't matter
because i'm winning pawns
yeah night before all of course a trade
okay that was nice game
oh patch tv bought my london course
but having trouble studying it
uh well there's videos that go along
with all the exercises
so if you're having trouble you can you
can watch the videos
and then maybe come back to the
exercises
yeah we do have the london command
to get the best price on the london
course
uh oh playing a good player
they're not berserking
i was looking at this other day like
early b5 and c5
so i think i'm threatening to take in
97.
okay a lot of trades there
some idea b4
[Music]
takes in b4 looks nice
so this is what we call the minority
attack it's two pawns swarming against
three pawns
i'd used to eventually have a weakness
to target
the weakness of c2
um
i'll reinforce
a very strategic game so far
i think i want to maneuver the knight to
c4
wow e3
um
taking makes sense
and what else to do
another option of 97
g97 i kind of like
it's a temporary pawn sacrifice i like
and take take and take
but
i think i have rook a1 and then follow
with the knight coming in
yeah
at first i thought i missed this move
but after it takes lightning f8 in
response to rook e8
i'm realizing the knight might want to
redevelop to c6
just target the pawns
now if takes takes rookie it is not me
because bishop
would take back
uh i think this makes sense
i wasn't sure about knight c6 bishop d5
in that line
it was probably okay but
safety first
i forgot the knight was defended
let me take
position looks nice but it's still very
much of a fight
that's a good move
i want to play rook 82 soon
hopefully it won't be too soon
b5 b5 i take the
bishop i'm preventing any rook b3
nonsense
okay this is a skewer now
a a
oh that's the first letter of the
alphabet
that's also the shortest word
you can mickey guy
really
i want to do things for the bishop but
i'll just win a pawn
um yeah i'll bring the king to f6
and that's kind of sheltered by the
pawns
hmm
[Music]
who's trying to mate who
g5
i'm losing all my pawns but i think i'm
just meeting
hopefully
probably
definitely
maybe
definitely maybe
i feel like that would be a decent like
quote to put on a mug
or a shirt
yeah
so the king is very much attracted to
the rook
this is pretty nice
okay a common meeting idea
uh white couldn't really stop it once uh
the spike checks ran out
okay let's go
12th place
ooh
yeah it's going to be hard to finish top
five top 10 is with insight
one win away from top 10
right
i'm playing the person in fourth place
a key game
yeah there's a threat of knight d5 here
i've had this position
it still works
and now i hit the queen
um so this is nice opening
yeah queen d2 i had 97 mate
hmm
you see four
actually c3
defend the pawn
i'm hitting e7
oh what to do
i probably want to go for d5 at some
point
a3
the black's controlling d5 with a lot of
things
so it still takes some work
ooh
well now the knight is a little bit
stuck on h4
g5 i would take it
um i don't think bishop a3 is such a big
threat
although maybe it's a little bit
unpleasant
how to do this
rook g3
i might want to play c4
which is a win connect four
mission accomplished
there's an idea of this and this
okay pawns are
the pawns are frowning but
okay this is this is leading to
happiness
uh
let's take up on
oh
my meeting
don't see mate
i think i just want to play this move
okay
it's like a little work
already passed a hundred that game
okay top ten
so only two losses this tournament
gain some rating
uh over an hour left still
yeah chicago chicago i think has been
playing since the start
ah queen b3
i guess queen's
it's a line here queen c8
yeah another example of a minority
attack
g4 might happen
yeah the whole point is to induce some
weaknesses
okay g4 happened
interesting
uh let's not play rook b3
maybe this move no
uh how to do this rp2
there would be two
i wasn't sure
thanks for subbing
on bassantosaurus that's an amazing
username
um
i'm not sure who's trying to attack on
the king's side
there's a funny line that ends with
queen a6
i'm threatening uh like if the pawn
takes or pushes jack and queen a6
with king f1
[Music]
because we have to trade
um
that didn't do anything
i have no time
this isn't oh this is really
bad oh there's a funny trick though
rook takes his rook beam on
ah
oh that was a difficult position to play
in time pressure it's a little bit too
slow
what should i do
okay
i'm gonna do with my top ten
yeah i have a lot of fives going that's
a nice berserking streak
ah
harvey 131
yeah my heart rate's getting closer to 5
5 5 5 etcetera
yeah the position was really nice in the
middle game i was just uh
yeah a little bit too slow there
okay i'm going back to my uh
real openings
or my main repertoire
yeah this is actually one of the best
ways for black to play this line
um but it's imbalanced
black has more center but i have the
bishop pair pressure
queen h4 ideas
this will end up trading
d5 is a target
i think the plan is just very simply
rook d2 rook d1
if knight here i think i play bishop f1
[Music]
also some knight h4 ideas
okay now there's three attackers
i guess e4 is a good move
now i have an idea of this and this
roxy five
i mean black is like purely defensive
after rook c5
but i'm not sure
if there's a knockout below
i'll still require these patients
now i want to do things
i play rook d2 to prepare this idea
so i've actually had a decent number of
games with
a similar situation
where there's bishops of the same color
and the opponent's pawns are on
the same color as a bishop
this one might be harder to win though
b4
um i have c4 here
just win a pawn
it gets weird though
yeah maybe you should not have allowed
this
oh there's a funny line though
i can start with taking
like here i take
like b3 of bishop d5
okay here i was looking at a3
i promise takes
um
i have to play this move
i don't know what else to do
i think i might just try and draw
it should be close to equal
okay box playing for a win
but i think black already like went
wrong because now i have this idea
and now i'm playing for a win
h4 reverge one
rook h2 okay i'll play take some takes
where could should i play king a3
air king b5
i'll actually have gone after the pawn
i might be losing this actually
i'm just losing or am i
i'm just losing
ah what should i do
oh the position was good again
[Music]
just a little bit uh
imprecise in the end game
blackout counter play
i had no time
to do
okay it gets tough
i have to persevere
played this opponent couple times in the
past
i've never been to finland i want to go
someday though
it's a risk berserking um i think it
still makes sense for the
like determined situation though
let's
take i'm stacking upon
it's probably a little bit reckless
um
i'll start with this move
the bishop e3 i take and play this and
hit multiple things
if queen e2
trade
yeah so i'm down the pawn here
i probably should have considered this
move but
there's bishop d3
d4
start with this
idea this and this
uh okay let's not blunder
i take
i mean i'll take and
accept triple pawns also divina what's
up divina
shout out to divina i appreciate the
raid if you're just joining i i just
have
triple pawns
no longer down the path
also quack
it's amsterdam
thanks hamsterham
yeah for everyone joining this is a
uh it's a yearly blitz arena it happens
once every year
and
i'm doing my best to finish strong
less than an hour left in the tournament
uh let's check
some idea c4
so
is key e2 or king c2
regardless i play c4
there's a funny line f4 knight d3 rook
c4 knight b2
which i think was actually okay for
white
um
c3
[Music]
just gotta move
mwah
mwahaha
knight d3
really risky but
i gotta try something
[Music]
i'll be losing a pawn
might be losing two pawns
that's already not looking good this
move
bishop d2 doesn't
maybe biz of d2
from bishop g5
i'm still down with pawn but
soon to be two pawns
it's completely losing but
still got a fight
please do it
i tried
there are so many stalemate tricks
there were a lot of still matrix towards
end there
why also got kind of low on time what to
do
um
[Music]
okay no more berserking
let's cut the losses
and
i'll still try and play quick and
aggressively
i just want to stop the bleeding
yeah i'm getting a workout this
tournament
i wonder how many calories i'm burning
like playing these games
uh let's play h4
h4 is like a newish idea
um
engine inspired
a lila stockfish a lot of the engines uh
we'll recommend each four in these sort
of positions
uh is this a move
look at this move
knight g6
so if takes i take the rook and then
i'll be up exchange and if takes i
can even take back and then take
i think i'm just winning
oh there's rook t8 though
lock's gonna find rook t8 yeah
not winning anything
let's take and move back
that was almost a cool tactic
so i'm hitting this pawn
[Music]
i do a um g5
and this knight is really out of play
black wants to play f6
uh
i think i just allow it
and play knight g6
now the pawns attacked
but it's yeah it's way more positional
queenside castle
so ideally i'd like to get a structure
with f4
i don't want to allow knight g5 so let
me start with this move
another idea is to play e4
play a4
um
the box handling this well
[Music]
knight g5 is probably coming
and i'll just accept the fact that it's
planting itself
hey it's gotham what's up gotham
shout out to levy
i appreciate the read
uh i hope you had a good stream
hope your dog is doing well
[Music]
if you're just joining i'm
i've lost the last three games in a row
i'm trying to
avoid
throwing a rolled out like temper
tantrum
but it's difficult
uh maybe f5
maybe g5
even though there's three things hitting
g5 i have
uh 95 tricks
ooh
yeah that's annoying move
if i take first doesn't really make a
difference
oh there's a funny line
okay
this might end badly for me but
it might end really well too
the point is after
black has a few options here
oh i have b4 as well
b4 d4
let's play b4
i was gonna take and taken rook 8 but
this is interesting
okay now i'll take and play rook a7
the white might just be completely
winning here
kind of a cool pawn diamond thing
with the imposter pawn
yeah knight takes i take with a rook and
then we simplify
and jagalgo passing 200 tournament
points
so here i go for this move
maybe you should have thought this
through
i think it's okay though
calculating this in the 95
i'm realizing it's not so simple
or is it so simple
it might be so simple i'm threading
maiden one
king f8 is made in two
knight g5 i push upon
it sounds pretty simple
yeah i was thinking just h7
and blocks a little bit stuck here
knight g6
it seems like there should be a few wins
this might actually be the simplest win
it looks scary but
let's do it
idea knight g6
oh no i'm getting forked
okay so i'm threading made in one
and i don't need a queen
and the black's not meeting me
the block's checking me
oh no my queen
okay
queen wasn't taken i would have rook 8
in the end
so um i'm trying to work my way back to
top 10.
it's not easy though
nigel short
okay back to berserking
if i take
maybe 95.
yeah the queen is a target
some cool idea queen g3
also a cool idea
attack the knight with everything wow
[Music]
black has cool ideas too
what does this move
i didn't see that coming
of queen queen e3
i don't think taking the queen works
it's about to get confusing
queen b8
i might as well take
so it's equal material black has a
bishop here
um knight c4 probably coming
hit the bishop
take with a rook
um
oh no
or oh yes
what's going on here
t3
i think it's okay
i don't know what's going on here
i think things are defended though
because there's a pin
don't hurt me
when you suffer i take with check
okay maybe now i can hurt the opponent
i'm the one who pins
it's still tricky though
because i have some background mate
vulnerabilities
although queen c6 i think i play this
queen c1 rook t1
i should probably move upon
h4
so still threatening this
never mind
or cure
hmm
rookie
[Music]
97 wow
[Music]
i feel attacked
don't hurt me
don't worry me
it's okay
i was scared of weird checks but it
worked out
let's go
both place
about 40 minutes yet left thank you
yaakov
the prime sub
okay
um
let's try and stay focused here
it's tiring playing so much chess
been live for over three hours i
appreciate people tuning in
um thanks to all the raiders and people
subbing and
being here
giving some nice energy
okay so white's kind of trying to play a
hippo
but i'm playing a crab
delayed crab
either want to play this or this i'm not
sure yet
okay probably this
yeah keeping the bishop
this is expected and then i'll play this
in this
i mean white doesn't really have too
many options here
oh
so bishop e2
probably bishop here
i mean liking castle
or that move
king f8
a little bit conflicted here
maybe i'll play
play this move
defend the pawn
now king f8
i'm keeping the rook on the h file is
there some idea of this and this
ah b4 is a good move
i'm in trouble
[Music]
i'm still like go all out though
to do this work here
c6 bishop b8
how to do this
oh no
don't hurt me
i'm knight d5 actually
and there's funny line takes takes takes
and check
and then takes
so maybe it's okay
time is dwindling
oh i didn't even see that move
i was scared of queen a1
my g7 pong was hanging
completely oblivious to that
maybe it's okay though
wow
okay i have to take
i always played well
and f4 i guess
[Music]
ah what to do
take this
doesn't work
wait what
i was not expecting rook b7
ah that's not quite stalemate
where's my stalemate trick
almost still means
i should probably resign
ah i flagged
i was also getting mated
oh what to do
yeah position was good from the opening
but then the center
kind of crumbled
okay it's going to be a challenge to
just finish in top 10.
31 minutes left
jagalko is going to be the clear winner
just have to make the final push
thank you love her
or love hater
i'll call you love her thanks for
subbing for six months in advance
thank you on pantosaurus eric your
content is an inspiration
i've never had so many opportunities for
self-improvement since getting married
quack doodle do
ah man
congrats on your marriage
okay so another berserking game
uh playing
trying to play aggressively
this is some
london line
if i take
bishop e5 is like a typical
typical resource for whites
there is pressure against d4
from multiple directions
two months yay quack
thank you e funnel
i want to keep the rook on each file
this move
looks a little bit sauce
idea oh
it was c3 but c3 doesn't work so
never mind
c pawn is pinned
okay so i lose a pawn
uh probably king f1
was reminiscent of the previous game
[Music]
g4 maybe
things are getting spicy
hey it's jane galt still believer
i'm trying i'm trying it's tough though
um the g5 should be coming g5 opens up
the queen as well
and the bishop
if this i play f3
quack
a lot of quacks thank you too crazy
person
a quack is a sound that a dog mate duck
makes but also a crazy person makes
all right knight h5
takes
queen h4 in the end
so f6 coming
it's really close to winning
i gotta go for this
i'm just not seeing the wind
d4
i thinking bishop d3
we trade
try it
so takes takes
i mean where's the meat
and it's gotta be made somewhere
remind me later
there's one check and then king ji one
pawn digs b2 i think it's made in like
three or four
oh thank you jingle for faster game
storm some kings gambit
i haven't played king's gander yet this
stream
so i'm down a piece here but material is
not so relevant
it's all about whether i can checkmate
and visual page 7 is probably what i
want to do
[Music]
king g1
mm-hmm
yeah where's the meat
[Music]
in this move
not seeing it
okay now writing mates
13 seconds left
letting it slip
no
oh my yep clock
yep clock didn't quite make it
uh
also black has a really nice defensive
resource queen g2 and
white's just losing here
um
i guess knight h5 also
it ended up working
is it nothing more than a draw
it was queen d7
white is slightly better
after
ah that's probably close to a draw
what to do
this crazy position
okay goal of top ten
top five is uh
very unrealistic at this point
still some fun games though
playing pursle bomber
napa is working back
going for
appearance
bishop h6 here
yeah so the main idea is h4h5
as king h8 is preparing this
it's a question how i break through on
the king side
not so simple
the a5 is interesting
maybe this and
[Music]
i think c7 but also pinning the pawn
also some idea knight e3 to f5
okay connect four
that's looking better here
some g5 ideas incoming
knight e3 still on the horizon
i probably want to start with like queen
f3 knight e3 g5
um
which pawn to take with probably this
pawn
and then still put the knight on e3
yeah so the ideal setup
where's my queen wanna go
queen probably wants to be on g3
and knight on e3
okay i'll avoid the bishop trade
oh no my bishop
so i'm threatening made in two
and it's not easy for black to stop
that's one way to stop it i can take and
take
um
i mean it's it's completely winning it's
just a matter how i wanna get things
done
thinking i'll leave the tension
and
go for rook g1
i mean
g6
uh g6 for the the lulz
[Music]
i still have to move quickly here
play this move
because the knight's completely
restricted
where's the wind
in this move
idea bishop f7
i just want to hug all of lax pieces
maybe not the cleanest conversion
simple plan h5 eventually take
uh
that's a move
i better not lose this
black is
unhugging me
now this is
gonna
be difficult to win now
i got a little bit too relaxed there
plenty of time
no
i'm so sad
i'm so sad with that cream
oh i primo queen h6
that's such a bad free move oh no
oh
what to do
yeah opponent dirty tricked me too many
times
oh what i do
i think it's the nature of like playing
playing almost four hours non-stop
let's try and
oh tracks our time
i haven't played the tracks already yet
this stream
okay no track sir
i don't know what i'm doing here
a little bit tilted from previous events
but actually i don't mind the position
idea h6 g5
oh no i blundered
it's going downhill
white's taking time though
yeah white finds it
oh what should i do my bishop's getting
trapped
b5 doesn't quite work or does it
no it doesn't work
um
well now i have to live with the
consequences
yeah h6 was bad i should have played um
an a5 move first
but i'll still try and fight here
either want to play pawn g for bishop g4
probably pawn g4
and then pawn h4
upon h5 playing punch 5 first
i think it's a little bit more flexible
93 is coming
f4 of all
if i take and take on c3
i gotta try this
um
there's like g6 in the end
or that move
okay still down the piece
and down on time
probably rookie five
i think i'm also threatening to take
white's giving me some hope
oh fancy
[Music]
play this move
should play b6 soon
create some passer
okay
just want to bolt down the board
the bishop is completely dominated by my
knight
and this knight is completely dominated
by my other
things i don't see how white stops the
pawn
let's go okay
wow
i didn't uh
i didn't
expect to win that i just lost a piece
in the opening and i deserved
but that's why you should always fight
okay
let's try and finish strong
it's still within range of top ten
[Music]
the same opening as previously
oh
okay no time to waste
let's go
so back on the berserking streak
some of these players have been playing
for almost six hours straight so
uh it's that time of tournament where
blunders are a bit more prevalent
hey thank you chimba hey eric any chance
you could say happy birthday to my chess
best friend sam
yeah happy birthday sam
let's get a chant
i'll make all of chat say happy birthday
sam
happy birthday sam
wait
is there no more chant command
how do i chant command
oh twitch got rid of the chant command
i'm playing
of berserk
but everyone can say happy birthday sam
okay at least i get to play the person
in first place
h6
not sure if i've seen this move before
f4 may be coming
zigo's also been playing for six hours
nonstop
um
i kind of blundered
bishop c2
there's queen b6 ideas but i'm hoping
something works
okay
i like the position now
that's probably the final game for me in
the tournament
this final game that counts for the
tournament
roxie a queen a6
i might lose c3 but
i might win a seven
[Music]
takes
no draw
because we're trading a bit
i have f5 here
we need to queen b4
that move i missed
oh
no i'm king
queen b2 is such a bad free move
also i i like i like queen bee one
hanging queen i play queen b2 hanging a
queen
oh what should i do
good game though
did that count for the tournament
it did
okay well that wraps up the tournament
13th place
out of almost 9 000 people
yeah the top five was a very ambitious
goal from earlier
but it was fun
oh chicago is streaming i wonder how
happy he was when he
he beat me like that
let's do some reaction
washing machine
wait let's see
oh no
[Music]
it's gonna be painful for me to relive
this
wow he's playing one-handed
with this
how do you do that
i guess it's normal to play one-handed
i was up 10 seconds
all i had to do was not blunder my queen
oh no it's about to happen
okay i was still up like six seconds
yeah no reason for queen b2
oh
what to do